[Musique]
encourage vraiment toutes les autres femmes à
poursuivre leur travail scientifique et à ne pas
abandonner leur carrière au milieu d'
un sale baku
[Musique]
c'est un grand honneur d'être sélectionnée pour
ce prix, je vais en utiliser un peu
bourse pour rendre visite à
d'autres représentants pour
travailler en collaboration et j'utiliserai également
cette bourse pour assister à plusieurs
conférences dans d'autres pays
[Musique]
mes recherches portent sur la bioproduction de certaines
molécules qui peuvent être utilisées dans de nombreuses
applications industrielles,
donc
fondamentalement, tous les matériaux que nous
utilisons actuellement  dans notre vie vient du
pétrole mais en réalité nous pouvons aussi fabriquer
ce composé à
partir de micro-organismes et nous pouvons également
créer un
système de production respectueux de l'environnement à l'aide de micro-organismes.
Nous savons que nous avons encore quelques difficultés à
entrer dans cette carrière scientifique en tant
qu'uma, en fait, dans la science, en tant que femme et homme.
n'a pas de différences sur ses
capacités ou ses connaissances en saya